there have been fish farms here at the
mouth of the Korean River in Penang
northern Malaysia for more than 40 years
but owners say the quality of the
seawater is degrading and they believe
that's causing their fish to die they
blame a nearby landfill for polluting
the water woman :
we depend on the sea for living if our
fish can survive we are going to have to
shut the farm if there's no fish in
these waters we'll be out of job as well
on the northern shores of Penang Island
Wang Thierry says his caged fish have
been dying as well he too blames the
water quality the state government says
the polluting of seawater may be caused
by run offs from an illegal quarry
operating nearby marine researchers say
the increase in jellyfish off the coast
of Penang is an indicator that the sea
water is becoming more polluted but say
there studies suggest that that's not
enough to cause fish to die as the same
pace you know it's difficult for us to
actually pinpoint on one factor the
ocean is a very dynamic environment it's
a both/and topo genic effects as well as
I'm due to climate change that causes
coastal pollution it's not just those in
the fishing and aquaculture industries
who are affected water sport operators
as well as hoteliers tell us that on
some days the pollution from this river
is so bad then the foul smell hangs in
the air and the water turns into a dark
almost black color on those days they
tell customers to avoid swimming in the
sea the local government says residents
have to do their part this so cost
illegal discharge into the drainage
system the people does not do the oil
Federation there just point to the
sewage system and check out the whole
system but the people here tell us they
don't think enough is being done to
ensure this proper environmental
monitoring nor tackle coastal pollution
Florence lui al Jazeera
Malaysia